(は)たくみさん、
(た)はいっ！
(は)2万人行きましたよ
(た)とうとう超えたね
(た)超えましたね
(は)やぁ〜、皆さん本当に
(は)あざっ!!
(は)たくみさん、なんか質問ないですか。
(は)なんか.......
(は)俺の予想では、
(は)春までに
(は)2万人行くと思ってたんすよ
(た)なるほど
(は)で、春までに2万人行くと思ってたんだけど、
(は)まさか1月の......終わり?!
(は)2月の初めに行ったってことは、
(は)速くないですか、ペース的に
(た)めちゃくちゃ速いと思いますよ
(た)えっ、もしかして、
(た)日本の
(た)学生で一番??!
(は)それね、ぱっと見ですよ
(は)今、学生ユーチューバー って中で
(は)多分ね
(は)暫定一位ですよ、今
(た)日本一??!
(た)抜きつ抜かれつ
(は)抜かれる、抜かれる
(は)ぱっと見、
(は)まあ、
(は)一位というわけで
(は)分かんないですけど
(は)2万人記念でなんか
(は)面白いことをしようと思ったんですけど
(は)今、テスト期間で忙しいんですよ
(は)ね?!
(た)ガチだね
(は)ガチです
(た)どんだけ忙しいか
(た)サブチャンネルに
(た)あげれ......
(は)あげて、あげて
(た)あげようか
(は)っていうわけで、今日もこの後、
(は)学校に行くんですけど
(は)まあ.....
(は)2万人行ったのは、
(は)みなさんのおかげですと
(は)いうことですよ
(は)というわけで、
(は)時間あったらっすよ、
(は)2万人記念動画出すかもしれないし、
(は)時間掛かったら、
(は)3万人に回すかもしれないんですけど、
(は)ちょっと、ハイクオリティーの物を
(は)作ろうかなってね
(た)なるほど
(は)では、今後とも
(は)このチャンネル
(は)よろしくお願いし ます
(た)よろしくお願いします
(は)勉強しよう
(た)しようか